it must be a cold day in hell because
the Biden Administration has just said
something sensible Joe Biden's Surgeon
General Vivek Murthy went on CNN to
explain that 13 year olds are simply too
young to be on social media
what is the right age for a child to
start using social media
I worry that right now if you look at
the the guidelines from the platforms at
age 13 is when kids are technically
allowed to use social media but there
are two concerns I have about that one
is I personally based on the data I've
seen believe that 13 is too early and I
think that it's a time you know early
adolescence where kids are developing
their identity their sense of self it's
a time where it's really important for
us to be thoughtful about what's going
into how they think about their own
self-worth and their relationships and
the skewed and often distorted
environment of social media often does a
disservice to many of those children but
the other concern I have is that these
rules around age are inconsistently
implemented
completely correct couldn't possibly
agree more but murthy's position on
social media for children seems a little
strange when you consider it alongside
his position on transgenderism for
children back in March Surgeon General
Murphy said quote yesterday afternoon in
Austin I met with transgender Youth and
their parents to hear how they are
coping in light of the state's recent
directive equating gender affirming care
to child abuse lgbtq plus youth were
already at increased risk of suicide and
other mental health struggles we should
be seeking to provide them with support
and Medical Care the Texas directive
threatens to do the opposite forcing
parents to choose between following
medical advice for their child and
risking an investigation from the state
is simply not right the government
shouldn't be interfering with decisions
between doctors and patients in other
words
children are too young to watch Dance
videos on Tick Tock but they're not too
young to castrate themselves they're
they're not mature enough to scroll
through memes on Twitter
but they're perfectly able to pump
themselves full of cross-sex hormones
irreversibly mutilate their bodies and
very possibly sterilize themselves
the Biden Administration has no problem
with little kids being groomed into
transgenderism by watching drag queen
Story Hour
just make sure the kids don't watch it
on Instagram I'm Michael Knowles this
the Michael Knowles show
[Music]
welcome back to the show my favorite
comment yesterday is from Stephen Wagner
who says when they warn people about
your episodes you're doing something
right fam that's true we did we got not
one but two warnings on YouTube just a
couple of days ago I'm not sure why is
it because I was talking about Pfizer is
it because I was talking about Joe Biden
is it I don't know it could be any of
the things that we talk about but they
want to make sure that you're
discouraged from watching it why
because they want to take power away
from you they want to take wealth away
from you they want to take your
traditional way of life away from you
one great way to protect against that
you got to check out Birch gold right
now text Knowles to 98 98 98
the U.S has blown through the 31.4
trillion dollar debt ceiling that
happened last month still the White
House refuses to reduce spending if
you're worried about the future of this
nation's economy you need to consider
diversifying into gold with Birch gold
Birch gold makes it easy to convert an
IRA or 401K into an IRA in Precious
Metals text nulls kwles to 98 9898 to
claim your free info kit on gold and
then talk to one of their precious
metals Specialists with an A plus rating
with the Better Business Bureau
thousands of happy customers and
countless five-star reviews you can
trust Birch gold to help protect your
savings
head on over there right now you can do
it by texting Knowles kwles to 989898
you can protect yourself with gold today
I have always enjoyed investing in
Precious Metals I'm thrilled to have
some Birch gold especially you know I'm
of Italian extraction we we love our
gold okay a really great way to start
diversifying especially in Crazy
Economic Times text Knowles can wles to
98 98 98 today
too young to scroll on Tick Tock
perfectly old enough to cut your
genitals off
as a point I noticed that from the daily
writer Tim Meads made made that great
observation it's really hard really
really hard to reconcile those two
things
the libs don't care about reconciling
them
I'm glad that the Biden Administration
is moving in the right direction on
social media but
let's follow that to its logical
conclusion folks and recognize that that
transgenderism which is not appropriate
for anybody of any age certainly is not
appropriate for children
speaking of children Minnesota has just
decided to legalize abortion
at any point in pregnancy
this according to Minnesota quote every
individual who becomes pregnant has a
fundamental right to continue the
pregnancy and give birth or obtain an
abortion and to make autonomous
decisions about how to exercise this
fundamental right this is the protect
reproductive options act every Democrat
in the Minnesota state house voted for
this and every Republican opposed it and
the governor whose Democrat says he'll
sign it into law
this now means that Minnesota is in the
same league as North Korea and communist
China when it comes to abortion much
much more radical than pretty much every
other country on Earth other than
North Korea China and Canada Canada
actually is also also there as well now
what the libs will tell you what the
pro-abortion people will tell you is
you fear-mongering conservatives you
like to pretend that abortions happen
late in pregnancies you like to pretend
that there could be abortions in the
ninth month of pregnancy but that just
doesn't happen you're worried about a
problem that doesn't exist
and the way that you know that this
argument is completely empty and
dishonest is that they changed the law
if this doesn't happen
why would they change the law
if this doesn't happen why did they
change the law to do this in New York
why did they change the law in Virginia
why did they now change the law in
Minnesota specifically to legalize
abortion at any point in pregnancy right
up until the moment of birth
you should put that argument right back
in their face and you say okay it
doesn't happen good then vote against
the law well it's not going to do
anything
so the law is totally ineffective isn't
it it's not going to have any effect in
the real oh it will why because it does
happen this reminds me of when Nancy
Pelosi said that the the wall that Trump
wanted to build on our Southern border
is cruel and inhumane and a terrible
thing to do and a violation of Human
Rights and also wolves don't work hold
on
when she has it if the walls don't work
then the wall is obviously not inhumane
and cruel and terrible in a violation of
Human Rights
if the wall is all of those things then
clearly the Wall Works it's got some
effect it's the same thing here
they are passing these laws
because late-term abortions do happen
and the libs don't want to defend
late-term abortions on the merits so
they say hey look over here it doesn't
really happen this is a made-up problem
don't listen to the conservatives and
then with their other hand they're
signing these barbaric laws into effect
speaking of child abuse
there is a BBC correspondent his name is
Mark lowen who just posted a picture of
him and his gay partner and a little
baby in an airport and this guy says
quote after six weeks in wonderful and
tearful farewells to our incredible
surrogate and friend it's time to go
home to Lisbon with our new family
member our most beautiful hand luggage
Canada you are a shining light of
democracy and equality thank you for
letting us fulfill our dream
and he is fulfilling a dream I have no
doubt that Mark lowen this BBC
correspondent is fulfilling his dream of
having a child with his gay lover
the cost of fulfilling that dream was
ripping a baby away from his mother
that was the cost
and this guy many other people in this
country are choosing to pursue that
dream that fantasy that delusion that
two men can be the same thing as a man
and a woman who are married and have a
family and have children
many many men and some women
are choosing to pursue that dream at the
cost of
tearing a newborn little child away from
his natural mother it's one of the worst
things that you can possibly do to
anybody on Earth if you've ever spent
any time if you have children yourself
you ever spent time as a little baby if
you were ever a kid once you might
remember some of this
little babies need their mothers and
when these very very selfish gay men
decide that they are going to put their
own
disordered desires
their disordered sexual desires and
their perfectly normal well-ordered
natural desire for a family when they're
going to just Mash those two things up
and the person who's gonna have to pay
the price for that is the little baby
who gets robbed of his mother that is a
terrible evil thing to do and Society
obviously should not tolerate that at
all but you're not really allowed to say
that anymore
we have to all pretend we have to be
just like
we talked about this yesterday on the
show all the people watching that
transgender ice skater who's a who's an
older man an older out of shape man
who's now pretending to be a woman and
trying to skate around during an ice
skating competition from Finland and he
can't really do it and then he falls
down and he can't get up and that's kind
of funny it's sad but it's funny it's
mostly funny this is just mostly sad
and it is a reminder
that
people do not have a right to a child
when we're talking about family when
we're talking about procreation the only
people who can be said to have any
rights whatsoever are the children a
child has a right to his natural mother
and father who are united together in
marriage in perpetuity and marriage is
an institution that unites husbands and
wives for the good of the spouses and
for the sake of the generation and
education of children gay men have no
right to purchase to rent the wombs of
poor women and to purchase the eggs of
poor women and to create children with
the express intent of of robbing those
children of their natural mothers that's
a really evil awful thing to do and I I
don't think that most of the people who
do this even really think about it I
don't think Mark lowen has ever really
considered that too much but
nevertheless it's a really evil thing to
do babies need their mothers okay and
some people have responded to this they
said well Michael
do you think that would you say the same
thing about heterosexual surrogacy
you're uh you sound like a big phobe you
know you sound like a big bigot well
look it obviously is different
it is worse when gay men and lesbian
women and single parents for that matter
do this than when a married couple does
this but it's all bad we should not be
renting the wombs of poor women and
purchasing the eggs of other women in
some cases
and creating children in in test tubes
to satisfy our own desires it has lots
of effects that people don't like to
take account of namely
it usually
involves the creation of lots of embryos
lots of little human beings who are then
locked away in freezers forever and ever
but beyond that
it it establishes the domination of
Technology over the origin and Destiny
of human life and corporations over the
origin and Destiny of human life and
that's and the state sometimes over the
that's a terrible thing to do this is
this is in on the one hand a kind of
cultural Marxism a radical dismantling
of our of our culture along new
atheistic absurd lines that's definitely
part of what's happening this is also
capitalism run amok the fact that we're
now treating women as Commodities as as
as places to be rented and that we're
treating eggs and sperm as Commodities
and that we're treating little kids as
Commodities are perfect most beautiful
new hand luggage
little pets little toys little doddles
to ornament are are consumerist lives
absolutely awful stuff don't do it I'm
sure I'm sure there are people who have
engaged in this who now regret it and
that's very sad and you got to make the
best of a bad situation for people I
know there are plenty of gay people who
listen to this show and who are
considering these things don't do it you
might not realize how evil it is now but
it is evil do not do it have I made
myself clear
I hope that I have
I absolutely hope that I have you know
the last thing the absolute last thing
that you are going to want to do when
you are hosting your friends for the big
game is go run out and have to fill your
propane tank okay so why do that when
you can check out cinch right now head
on over to cinch.com offer get ahead of
the game this year with cinch cinch is a
propane grill tank Home Delivery Service
delivers propane tanks right to your
door cinch delivers on your schedule no
long-term commitment or subscription
required plus delivery is completely
contactless you don't have to be home to
receive the delivery you can track the
order on the Cinch app from anywhere are
you looking to exchange your tanks cinch
handles that whole process for you so
you don't have to go to the hardware
store or gas station you can exchange
any brand of tank as long as it is
standard Grill size you choose your
delivery date and cinch handles the rest
go online to cinch.com or download their
app to order new customers can get their
first tank exchange for just 10. with
promo code Knowles kwles go to cinch.com
or download the Cinch app use promo code
Knowles kwles to get your first tank
exchange for just 10 bucks
c-ynch.com promo code Knowles Canada
wlas this is a limited time offer you
must live with an essential service area
to redeem it go to cinch.com offer for
details
speaking of raising children
Ron DeSantis down there in Florida the
hits just keep on coming Ron DeSantis is
looking to cut the diversity
equity and inclusion staff at
universities
DeSantis
has said that he plans to quote
eliminate all Dei and CRT bureaucracies
in the State of Florida such that the
programs Wither on the vine
that's wonderful wonderful news in
recent years the Dei programs at these
universities have just multiplied and
now it seems like for every one student
for every one Professor there were three
Deans and Deputy Deans and Deputy
assistant Deputy deans of diversity
inclusion and stirring up a bunch of
racial and sexual resentment to the tune
of four hundred thousand dollars a year
per employee and it's just it's just a
disaster
so de Santa says he's going to fire all
of them
great stuff he went on to say that Dei
bureaucracies are quote hostile to
academic freedom and constitute a drain
on resources that's true but
but that's a good thing
academic freedom is a bad thing
and this is some place that some
conservatives have gotten a little
confused recently but
academic freedom the notion that
professors have the right to teach
whatever the hell they want in the
classroom that is not true and it's not
conservative in fact you know I'm right
now I'm I'm broadcasting from my library
because the daily wire studios are shut
down I realized I have a book right back
there it's William F Buckley Jr's God
and man at Yale this is a book credited
with launching the post-war conservative
movement but the the subtitle of that
book
you might be able to see is the
superstitions of academic freedom in
that book which launched the modern
conservative movement Buckley who is as
mainstream a conservative as ever there
was calls academic freedom a hoax he
says it's complete BS of course teachers
don't have the right to teach whatever
they want
the students have the right to an
education education involves being
taught the truth
the trustees
of the University have have the right to
have some say over over
what is taught in the classroom if it's
a public university taxpayers have a
right to some say over what is taught in
the classroom
the weirdo Professor with the crazy hair
and and the wacky ideas about sex and
race and taxes for that matter they
don't have rights they have they have
the right to academic freedom in the
sense that they can pursue their own
researches on their own time
they don't have the right to teach kids
whatever they want
now maybe DeSantis knows that he's a
pretty sharp guy maybe he knows that
he's just using this phrase because he
knows it's popular but the fact that Dei
bureaucracies are hostile to academic
freedom that's my favorite part of Dei
bureaucracies the problem is they're
hostile to academic freedom
in that they censor professors from
teaching true things and make the
professors teach false things
but what we are very much for stopping
professors from teaching false things
and making them teach true things okay
DeSantis goes on he says the most
significant deadweight cost at
universities is typically unproductive
tenured faculty why would we want to
saddle you as taxpayers with that cost
if we don't have to that also is not
quite true the tenured faculty
are not my problem my problem is the
administrators small private colleges
right now are spending almost twice as
much on administrators as they are on
academics all the professors the tenured
ones the not tenured ones they're
spending twice as much on the
administrators the Deans and the deputy
Deans and all these Dei weirdos the
number of Administrators at colleges and
universities
has grown twice as fast over the over
the 25 years ending at 2012 as the
number of students did the reason that
we don't have new data on this right now
is because it's just very difficult to
to track accounting at these various
colleges the colleges are very opaque
about the whole matter but we do have
these data for 25 years leading up to
2012 I promise you the situation has
gotten way worse since then
and the admin has grown twice as fast as
the kids this is madness and that's just
according to one analysis by the New
England Center for investigative
reporting so great stuff absolutely love
that DeSantis is doing this acts all of
these people
cut their pensions get get them out of
there send them to another state put
them on the next Venezuelan Airbus up to
Martha's Vineyard get them as far away
from the students as possible now
speaking of DeSantis Rhonda Santos has
finally responded to the many attacks
coming his way from president kofe
Donald Trump has been attacking Ron de
sanctimonious he's been hitting him
specifically on what is perceived to be
desantis's strengths that would be the
lockdowns and the covid policies in
Florida desantis's team has said we had
the model covid policies and many people
have insinuated that Florida never
locked down at all Trump is now saying
no he actually did lock down for a
little bit which is true but not nearly
as long as federal government advised
people to lock down so anyway they're in
this kind of slapping match and DeSantis
has finally slapped back just a little
bit
I roll out of bed I have people
attacking me from all angles it's been
happening for many many years and if you
look at the good thing about it though
is like if you take a crisis situation
like covid you know the good thing about
it is when you're an elected executive
you have to make all kinds of decisions
you got to steer that ship and the good
thing is is that the people are able to
render a judgment on that whether they
re-elect you or not and I'm happy to say
you know in my case not only did we win
re-election we won with the highest
percentage of the vote that any
Republican governor candidate has in the
history of the state of Florida
we won by the largest raw vote margin
over 1.5 million votes than any uh
governor candidate has ever had in
Florida history and in fact we almost
doubled the previous record which I
think was like 780 000 vote margin and
so what I would just say is uh that
verdict has been rendered by the people
of the State of Florida
and there it is now we have the DeSantis
sales pitch straight from the man
himself and the sales pitch is
at least I can get elected that's the
pitch Trump's sales pitch is there's no
such thing as trumpism without Trump I'm
one of a kind I'm the only one who can
fix the problems all these other guys
are copycats of me there would be no Ron
DeSantis without me I pulled him over
the Finish Line forget about them
they're the wannabes I'm the real deal
and now desantis's answer is yeah well
at least I can get elected
at least I beat Joe Biden now this is a
good line of argument but it's not going
to be persuasive to people who think
that the 2020 election was stolen
it's not it's not going to be persuasive
in a way it might be a mark against
DeSantis
the people who are really down the
rabbit hole of election Shenanigans in
2020. will say maybe it's actually a
mark against DeSantis that he got
elected the fact that they the people
who control the elections they let him
get elected is actually a mark against
him and that's why I gotta I gotta go
for Trump all of that said though
what's Trump's answer to that is is the
argument now just well
uh yeah that's true they want they're
gonna keep stealing it from Trump and
that's why we have to nominate him
so what they're going to steal it again
what's the plan until the Trump Camp can
come up with a good persuasive answer to
that
then Ron desantis's sales pitch which
right now is just I can get elected I
can get elected by wide margin it's a
very persuasive sales pitch
speaking of politicians with santis in
their name
Congressman George Santos has just
announced that he will step down from
his committee assignments he won't
resign from the Congress but he will
step down from his committee assignments
he says quote with the ongoing attention
surrounding both my personal and
campaign Financial investigations I've
submitted a request to speaker McCarthy
that I'd be temporarily recused from my
committee assignments until I am cleared
this was a decision I take very
seriously okay he probably had to do
this that the Press are hounding him
constantly there's there are new
allegations that crop up seemingly every
day
that he lied about his education lied
about his employment history lied about
his sexual desires possibly maybe was a
criminal in Latin America
I don't know if anything about this guy
is is honest or trustworthy at all
some Democrats have said you saw this
line floating around social media they
said if George Santos was a Democrat he
would have been kicked out of Congress
the Democrats would have forced their
fellow Democrat out of Congress if
George Santos were a Democrat he
wouldn't just be stepping down from the
Committees he'd be all the way out of
Congress you know what I say I say if
Congressman George Santos were a
Democrat he would be Senator Elizabeth
Warren this who he would be because
George Santos
may or may not have lied about having a
Jewish Grandma I actually don't know he
might have had a Jewish Grandma the
whole joke was he said he was Jewish
that he was he didn't practice the
Jewish religion but he had a little bit
of Jewish Heritage somewhere maybe he
did I don't know don't know don't really
care uh what I do know is that he didn't
uh lie about being a Native American and
then get a career in Academia out of
that
and he's not a U.S senator he's a
congressman he's not even I think that
if George Santos were a Democrat
he would he would probably be President
Joe Biden because George Santos he lied
about what high school he went to and
his college degrees and all that
Joe Biden had to drop out of the 1988
presidential race because of this
because he lied about
I think essentially every statement he's
ever made about his educational
background was a lie graduated with
three degrees graduated in the top half
of his class got a departmental
distinction
because of his academic Acumen was there
on an academic scholarship all that was
just made up uh he also then had to drop
out of the race for plagiarism which is
the academic crime that is the crime
that shows that you don't have academic
Integrity uh so no
uh you're not going to get me to call
for George Santos's resignation okay
he's clearly a pretty weird guy
politicians are weird guys he might be a
little on the more extreme side of
things but
par for the course in that profession
George Santos is dishonest politicians
are dishonest he might be a little more
extreme maybe maybe in that direction I
don't think so Liz Warren steps down Joe
Biden steps down then you come to me and
you say George Santos needs to step down
until then he's he's an important vote
we have a razor thin majority I don't
want to hear it I don't want to hear it
about George Santos okay speaking of
Hispanic men
there are a bunch of illegal immigrants
in Manhattan there are a lot of illegal
immigrants in Manhattan but there's a
specific group of illegal immigrants in
Manhattan right now came up from Texas
who are staying at a luxury hotel
and
they don't want to leave
the city wants them to leave the hotel
they've been at a very nice luxury hotel
for quite a while now City says hey can
you would you guys mind leaving
they say no no gracias
Midtown they found work over there
they'd be in the middle of nowhere they
say sleeping next to the ocean he could
have easily along with Governor Hogle
opened up all the bacon luxury
apartments we are on 57th Street right
now this is billionaires Road half of
the super Towers on this street are
empty very basic beds head to foot no
space in between them there's four
bathrooms in the entire facility for a
thousand beds they've described multiple
security gates to get in they've
described that there's only food during
Limited hours and that sometimes the
water runs out and importantly also it's
cold in there despite the mayor's claim
that it's heated they said it was cold
in there
first thing I can't help but notice
about that little video clip
not seeing a whole lot of mothers and
widows and poor little orphan children
and dreamers you know that we're told
that the illegal aliens pouring across
our border to the tune of 2 million a
year
that they're they're just they're the
dreamers
the sweet little dreamers the sweet
little babes you want to turn away the
sweet little babes
now could you the poor women just
fleeing political they don't that
doesn't look like that to me looks to me
like a bunch of able-bodied young men
without any families at all who are just
trying to make a buck
and who are specifically complaining
about how if they go to Brooklyn it's
not going to be as easy for them to make
money because right now they're in
Manhattan they can make money in
Manhattan they go to Brooklyn they're
going to have to take the Subway or
something and so that's going to be
inconvenient for them and they they want
to stay at the luxury hotel on the
taxpayer dime
that's the first thing I can't help but
notice the second reaction I cannot help
but entertain is sheer Delight I think
this is just great
I think this is great because the New
York City government has said that it is
a sanctuary city right give them
Sanctuary they've said come over here
please you huddled
fighting age men come over here without
your families because you're yearning to
be free we'll welcome you
well no not here
no when we said we'll welcome you we met
in Texas
we met in California we met in Florida
we met in Arizona wait here
New York all right maybe you can go out
by the water out by where the mob works
at and wait Manhattan no you can't be
here in Manhattan that's where we live
you know you can't be here I get out of
our nice hotels please can you get out
no
please por favor no no gracias no
no no quiero Olive is that what you is
that how you say to leave I don't really
know I don't speak Spanish nor do the
New Yorkers they can have a hard time
communicating with their new neighbors I
think that's just great
if the New Yorkers don't want them there
if mayor Eric Adams is begging Joe Biden
he's going on TV we gotta we gotta do
something about this you got it we need
this out we got to fix this now okay
well if it's a problem for New York it's
a problem for Texas it's a problem for
Arizona problem for Florida
from for America
speaking of Shady congressman
Adam Schiff is going to run for Senate
Adam Schiff you know was leading the
charge of the first impeachment against
Donald Trump Adam Schiff
is a a shill and a hack who led so much
of the Russia gate hoax
and uh he he got the whole story wrong
and he either lied or was so incompetent
that he just unwittingly got the story
wrong but he got the story so wrong he
was so the boy who cried wolf during the
Trump years that even CNN is calling him
out for it
you said that there was direct evidence
of the fact that Donald Trump colluded
with Russia back in 2016. special
counsel Robert Mueller said in his
report quote the investigation did not
establish that members of the Trump
campaign conspired or coordinated with
the Russian government Republicans argue
that's proof that you used your position
on the intelligence committee to
intentionally mislead Americans which is
why you should not be on that committee
if you read the Mueller report he makes
clear even in the first few pages of the
report that he States no conclusion on
whether Donald Trump and his campaign
colluded with the Russians let me give
you another he says that um this is part
of the of a pattern ahead of the first
Trump impeachment you said the committee
had not spoken to a whistleblower in
fact that turned out not to be true you
know the Washington Post uh said so in
their in their fact check the one she
posts identified that yes before the
person became a whistleblower they
sought advice from the committee uh when
I was asked the question I thought they
were referring to whether we had brought
the Whistleblower in uh and I should
have been more clear in my answer
I should have been more clear you see it
was all a big understanding not only did
Schiff try to to weasel his way out of
of lies and manifest falsehoods that he
has told whether wittingly or
unwittingly oh yeah I just misunderstood
the question but he goes further he he
basically defends the Russia hoax
that's his story and he is sticking to
it
but no we've we're supposed to disavow
George Santos I don't care about George
Santos okay not saying I would leave him
here to manage my finances or babysit my
kids or trust him really with anything
whatsoever but I don't I don't want to
hear about that when you've got
forget about Joe Biden and Elizabeth
Warren when you've got the atom shifts
of the world leading in the Democrat
Party about to get a promotion from
Congressman to Senator don't talk to me
about
don't talk to me about George Santos
Mike Pompeo former Secretary of State
and former CIA director points at Adam
Schiff
leaked classified information
what say you about the speaker's
decisions so I had the incredible
privilege to serve on that committee uh
it covers the most classified most
difficult stuff not every member of
Congress gets to see the information
that the intelligence committee sees and
Adam Schiff lied to the American people
and during my time as CI director and
Secretary of State I know that he leaked
classified information that had been
provided to him now the fact that Adam
Schiff was the chairman of the house
intelligence committee almost ruined
that committee it serves an incredibly
important function for the American
people speaker McCarthy got this one
exactly right Adam Schiff should be
nowhere near serving on the intelligence
committee I don't think he should be
seeing classified information
absolutely right there it is but we've
got to worry about Donald Trump a
president who had full authority to
declassify whatever he wanted he had
some some papers at Mar-A-Lago we have
to worry about that send in the Marines
send in the FBI to kick the door in
meanwhile you've got Adam Schiff
actively leaking classified information
they had absolutely no right to leak I
just don't want to hear it guys don't
want to hear that manufactured outrage
you know Valentine's Day is coming up
are you looking for a gift for your
trigger warning man if so and you think
it's right to reward a guy who works
hard plays with his kids and upholds the
patriarchy every time he holds the door
then pick up a Valentine's bundle from
Jeremy's razors now 30 off there is the
new Precision 5 razor with six months of
blade refills the luxurious beard kit
with beard oil shampoo bomb and a Boar's
hair brush or the best-selling body
bundle with charcoal body wash shampoo
and conditioner you love your man well
companies hate his guts kick them out of
his bathroom with a Jeremy's Razor's
Valentine's bundle now 30 off because
nothing says I love you quite like I
don't hate you just make sure to order
by February 7th to receive it by the
14th go to jeremy'sraisers.com
speaking of embarrassing Democrat
Congressman here's a new one have you
heard of Representative Sarah Jacobs
Sarah Jacobs I I had not heard of her
before this she is a backbencher
Democrat Congressman I guess she has
some interesting theories on state power
and biology
24 states have banned abortion or are
likely to do so
without Roe Americans are now facing a
confusing Patchwork of state laws
dictating who can make decisions about
their health care and when
without row state governments are
forcing pregnancy on people maternal and
infant Health Care outcomes are
worsening
William put a pause right there
the state governments are forcing
pregnancy how are they doing that would
you say
well because they ban abortion how do
you
how does Sarah Jacobs think that
pregnancy begins
when a man and a woman at least I don't
know this is how it used to be when a
man and a woman love each other very
much
they go out they get married then they
do this thing and then that's that's how
you get a baby now of course it involves
catalogs of people and hundreds of
thousands of dollars in test tubes and
all sorts of weird Canadian laws and but
previously that was that but under no
circumstances
does the state Force somebody to become
pregnant what the state does in this
country is
in certain parts of the country
uh not permit women to kill their own
children so it is true the state
forces people to
accept the consequences of their actions
and to respect the humanity of their own
children
in some cases in some parts of the
country in other parts of the country
you can kill the kids you can trans the
kids you can purchase kids like
Commodities but in some some parts of
the country
it's true you don't get to kill your kid
but in no part in no part will will the
state impregnate you yet yet we don't
know I mean I guess our national day is
still still quite young speaking of
democratic women
trying to explain things Kamala Harris
gave a rousing oratory uh just the other
day in which she explained how rocket
ships work
which brings me to May 30th 2020.
Bob and Doug returned to the Kennedy
Space Center
they suited up
they waved to their families
and they rode an elevator up nearly 20
stories
they strapped in to their seats and
waited as the tanks beneath them filled
with tens of thousands of gallons of
fuel
and then
you launched
yeah they did
they did
they did that
that's what a rocket ship is Kamala
Harris
sounds to me like the student in your
class who thought that essays and term
papers and even question and answer
sessions
were were just about filling the space
with words
that's that's all that it was about this
is this woman has less to say than any
person I have ever seen in public life
she talks just as much as anybody in
public life but she has nothing to say
what is it what is one thing that Kamala
Harris has ever said that has carried
with it any meaning
there's there's one answer to this as
far as I'm concerned and it's during the
Democrat primaries in 2020 she called
Joe Biden a racist
that's the one thing she ever said that
was
seemed concrete seemed like it had a
purpose seemed specific and then by the
way she walked it back and she said no I
don't think he's racist but he's a he he
supported segregation he was going to
keep me off a school bus or something
and
that was other otherwise it's just wow
microscopes allow you to see small
things and rocket ships go boom
wow and it goes up and then wow huh
duh it's very it would be very sad
I was going to say that she's the the
least impressive politician I've ever
seen it's not true she's very impressive
I am impressed by her vicuity I am
impressed by her vipity and I can't
imagine that life could you imagine
you go into politics you suffer the
slings and arrows all of the attacks
people make on you you forego in in many
cases making better money elsewhere
there I don't know about Kamala Harris
but there are plenty of politicians who
could make way more money in the private
sector than they do in government I'm
not saying she doesn't make a good
salary as a VP or a senator but she
could she could probably make more money
in the private sector you you get to
spend more time with your family when
you're not in government
you go through all of the this the
indignities that go along with holding
office for what for no purpose
whatsoever just to be there just to be
the vice president
there isn't Kamala Harris doesn't want
to do anything in office she has no
agenda whatsoever
she's a completely empty suit
not a whole lot going on I think between
the ears certainly not a whole lot going
on between the shoulders in terms of her
heart in terms of what stirs her in
nothing at all
she like kind of likes Joe Biden she
just wants to be the vice president
probably ultimately to be the president
could you possibly imagine speaking of
artificial and contrived things the FDA
is just given the go ahead
to lab-grown meat now lab-grown meat is
different from
veggie burgers lab-grown meat is
different from the impossible burger or
the I think Burger King was serving
these for a while they're vegetarian but
they look kind of like meat and they
even are kind of Juicy
and that's not what this is this is this
is actual meat
just not mostly not from animals
the agency says that it considers
chicken that is cultivated from cells
that come from stem cells and all sorts
of weird Frankenstein kind of stuff the
FDA considers this safe for humans to
eat after a review of a chicken product
from upside foods which is a company out
of Berkeley
now this won't be hitting the stores
just yet because they still need to sign
off from the U.S department of
Agriculture the USDA and the FDA team up
to decide which foods you're allowed to
eat but the way it works is that the the
meat the fake meat is cultivated from
real animal cells and so the CEO of
upside Foods a woman named Uma valetti
says that they are quote like a starter
dough it means it's not vegetarian means
that sometimes animals are killed and
eggs are used in the process of this but
but many many fewer animals are are
killed to obtain the same amount of meat
and to all of this I say
[Music]
no thanks
I'm good
no but it tastes the same it probably
doesn't but even if it does nah no thank
you but this is a way where you can have
your meat and not kill the animal too
you can have you this is a way where you
can have the best of all worlds yeah no
I'm good thanks though thanks for the
offer
but why why look rationally on paper
it's all upside and there's no downside
yeah I guess I just don't really believe
you I don't trust the FDA I don't trust
these Regulators I don't trust the
scientists I don't trust these
fads in modern hyper scientific
meats and other food products
I just don't trust that
it seems to me that every new brand new
food fad based on some
highly engineered type of food in the
last many decades has been very bad for
us
and it's always been the same story
the story is this new scientifically
engineered food is really really good
for you and it's way better than all the
traditional foods and you should just
replace all those traditional foods with
this new cheap chemical stuff that we're
giving you
and then what happens some Years Ago by
decades go by and you find out all that
new weird scientifically engineered
stuff is terrible my prediction
this isn't even just my prediction but
sweet little Elisa made this prediction
too so that's how you know it's that's a
good one is that this stuff
is going to be the seed oils of 20 years
from now
so my part of the prediction is that
this lab-grown weird meat that's going
to be the seed oils of 20 years from now
what I know for sure and I'm totally
with sweet little Elise on this
Cricket powder which the libs are all
now trying to put in our Foods
and succeeding in some cases it's going
into Foods in Europe and it's already
here in America in some places
that is going to be the seed oils of of
20 and 30 years from now mark my words
and we are going to go right but just as
we're as we're seeing right now with
oils and fats and the way that we cook
foods we're we're now ditching the
soybean oil and the canola oil and the
it's called rapeseed oil right it's
right there in the name rapeseed we're
ditching all that stuff and saying
actually you know butter is not so bad
for you actually olive oil and kind of
traditional stuff is not so bad for you
it's going to be the same thing here
with the lips who are trying to make us
eat the bugs and the weird Frankenstein
meat grown in the lab but don't worry
because the genius scientists at the FDA
and all the other Regulatory Agencies
they're telling us it's all fine and
when have they ever gotten something
wrong when it when have they ever been
proven around on public health or any
other matter I'm now at the point where
if the FDA tells me to do something I am
inclined to do exactly the opposite
now we had a marvelous marvelous
member block for you today
but unfortunately we were booted out of
our Studios severe weather in Nashville
has us all hunkering down
and because I do not have the
technological
apparatus of our main frame at the
headquarters we're going to have to hold
that for tomorrow all right how's that
for a cliffhanger folks in the meantime
make sure you head on over to daily
wire.com
enter promo code knows you can become a
member you'll be ready for that that
inner circle tomorrow I'll see you then
[Music]
foreign